hundreds of climate activists have
broken through a police line and stormed
one of germany's biggest like lignite
coal mines several police officers have
reportedly been injured it's the
culmination of a mass protest organized
by several environmentalist groups
activists are demanding that Germany
take immediate action to phase out
fossil fuels so as to limit global
warming for more on this let's go to DW
correspondent Peter Hilla who's at the
gotz viola lignite mine for us Peter
welcome we're hearing reports about
clashes between protesters and police
how is the situation where you are the
situation is very tense here at the
enormous open-pit mine of God's fire
that you can see behind me about 1,000
activists have entered that mine today
in the afternoon and now it's a standoff
between them and police down there in
that mine they're hard to spot because
this is an enormous pit it's about 66
square kilometers big but I just had a
look through binoculars and there you
can see really hundreds of policemen
facing hundreds of protests as some of
them have set up their tents so it's a
very tense situation down there that's
why the lignite mine belongs to energy
giant Ave a conflict between the energy
supplier and environmentalist isn't new
what's behind it well it's a conflict
between environmentalists and the coal
industry the environmentalists the
protesters here say that and the
initiative via the lignite mining in
this area is the main source of co2
emissions in Europe they say and so they
wanted to be shut down as soon as
possible and every year the the one
running this mine and some power plants
around here and other mines of course
says no we need to burn that coal we
need that energy from the ground here
now Germany has announced that it will
stop using coal as an energy source by
2038 politicians are even talking about
bringing the deadline forward to 2030
how far along is Germany with the
transition well Germany is not wait
wants to be and the lignite mining the
brown coal mining in the country is one
of the reasons for that because it is
called well
Wurst and energy production when it
comes to co2 emissions as I said it is
considered to be the main the biggest
single source of co2 emissions in Europe
and that is a reason why Germany won't
meet its climate goals if these minds
will keep running and the power plants
in this region will keep running for
another 20 years and that is why
politicians are now discussing after
they reached a compromise in phasing out
brown coal mining until 2030 8:00 and
they are now discussing new dates in
order for Germany to achieve its goals
so have protests like this one you're
following their forests effective energy
supplies at all no not at all not yet
every year the energy supply here in the
region of course they have stockpiles of
their coal and not far from here I can
see smoke coming from chimneys of their
power plant so they are still running
these power plants and even if some of
these power plants were to be shut down
of course there's other sources of
energy in the country so I don't expect
that we will see any sort of power
shortages in Germany in the near future
GW correspondent Peter Hilla thank you
very much